le chantier a démarré aujourd'hui fermée
depuis 2012 la destruction du silo de
coignières a démarré et les travaux
prendront environ deux mois avant de
faire place nette pour la construction
d'un nouveau parking à proximité des
habitations de la résidence des acacias
et du centre commercial coût de cette
démolition 400000 euros est les propos
recueillis par mathilde et demi
c'est un peu paradoxal à un silo qui
contenait au départ 4 174 places de
parking qu'on détruit pour faire à la
place des places de parking voilà donc
on aura une 70 places à peu près de
parking avec un aménagement paysager ce
qui va quand même vraiment transformer
la le quartier ça va errer le quartier
et ensuite en accord avec séquences mais
ça nous verrons en septembre le plan
d'aménagement
il y aura d'autres aménagements dans le
secteur qui seront effectuées